I woke up on Saturday and Amsterdam
around 9:30 extravagantly jet-lagged
what six feet tall and should have woken
up an hour ago then enjoyed the canal
view from my window for a few moments
before it occurred to me that I was
naked from the waist down so I got
dressed standard shot of brushing teeth
and met Henry's old babysitter Marcia we
walked down to the apartment where I'd
lived while finishing The Fault in Our
Stars of building a century older than
my country had an excellent cup of
coffee while marveling at the fact that
Amsterdam spouse square contains more
english-language bookstores than my
entire hometown of 1 million people I
only had two free hours so we raced
through the van Hien - and I paid to pee
it to the loo enjoyed some excellent
graffiti eight Vlaams of freed
autographs and books almost got hit by
the tram ate some herring almost got hit
by this cyclist bought season 2 of
Sherlock and then walked down toward the
Vondelpark to relive Gus & Hazel's wish
here's the hotel - Phyllis oaf and here
is the number one tram and here's the
cafe at the old film Museum in the park
and here's the tree as it looks at and
here are the epin which aren't yet
snowing and here is Peter Van Houten 's
house and here's the inn Frank asked
which they don't want you videotape and
here's the view hazel and Gus have
sitting on the bench beside the Prince
and a croc canal after their dinner and
here is the bar where a guy threw a
glass of beer at me when I x1 their 30th
league championship I don't mean he
threw the beer inside a glass at me I
mean he threw both the beer and the
glass at me and when I was like hey you
know we're both supporting the same team
here he said and I'm quoting him
directly right that has nothing to do
with the book back to Amsterdam I had a
series of interviews that afternoon in
the hotels fancy library where I would
be all like I had to reconcile myself to
it before I could write right god I hope
I sound less done when they translate
that to Dutch anyway this was all in
support of the publication of a movie
that I don't speak Dutch the beautiful
Dutch edition of The Fault in our
knoweldge
then I walked down to a canal boat where
I took pictures of someone taking
pictures of me and I hung out with
writers and journalists and my friend
yet who has more courage than I do we
got to see the central library of
Amsterdam on our trip where I wrote much
of The Fault in Our Stars sitting right
there and then we had to do a theater
where I got to listen to a presentation
about the mathematics and The Fault in
Our Stars that discuss Venn diagrams and
Hazel's incorrect assumption that there
are more whole numbers between 0 & 2
then there are between 0 & 1
No
liova and Lada sang me a song about
homoerotic Sherlock watercolors and
presented me with hula artwork
afterwards I walked over to blossom
which was the inspiration for the
restaurant Gus and hazel visit and then
got lost walking around the city haze
was wrong about infinite cardinality but
she's right that some infinities are
larger than others I wanted her to be
wrong but right because that's how we
muddle through as observers of the
universe
forging meaning where we can find it
from fact and fiction alike and as my
brain drowned in jet lag I thought of
the months I lived here so much of that
time I was sick and crippled with
anxiety but all I could think about now
as night fell was how much you can love
made-up people and how much you can miss
them Hank I'll see you on Friday